[Musica]
sanseverino di fare la recensione di un
film
[Musica]
non lo sapevi sono finita all'interno
proprio perché non posso più fare
recensioni sì ma si dà il caso che io
posso darti qualcosa in cambio sentiamo
posso farti tornare in vita vuole fare
le recensioni di sto cazzo di film e
facciamogli la recensione
il film inizia con uno scienziato
barbuto un parente di daniel bryan che
dopo aver scoperto robe scritte su una
lastra di pietra
entra dentro una catacomba inizia a
martellare
[Musica]
lo so lo so che volete un commento su
questi zombie ma lasciate passare
qualche minuto di film per ora vi lascio
assaporare
[Musica]
bella la musica fa molto un detective in
corsia
[Musica]
qual è la trama il professore di prima
aveva organizzato una festa ogni tanto
il conte george soglie il loro figlio e
altra gente inutile che gentilmente si
accomodano
[Musica]
ok grazie mille per questi incubo grazie
tra l'altro c'è qualcosa di strano in
questo bimbo non so
l'altra coppia intanto si rilassa a modo
suo ma che cosa stai facendo è certo
perché la prima cosa che ti viene in
mente da chiedere vedendo una donna in
intimo e che cosa stai facendo sta
chiaramente imparando delle cotolette
alla milanese perché la 10a the nation
sembri proprio una vignetta e sembri
proprio una [ __ ]
questa frase entra di diritto nelle fasi
più romantiche del mondo dopo si è amore
è un termine troppo debole ecco io ti
strano sai che adamo chiamava abramo
troppo debole sono venuto stasera perché
quando ti accorgi che vuoi passare il
resto della vita con qualcuno vuoi che
il resto della vita cominciò il più
presto possibile se sembri proprio una
[ __ ]
[Musica]
e mentre loro si divertono a fare il
pappone e la [ __ ] arriva qualcuno
sì entro capodanno che avrei preso degli
impegni e il piccolo michael che
continua ad avere qualcosa di strano
i capelli forse ma nel frattempo un orda
di zombie incredibilmente lenti si
avvicina
[Musica]
il giorno dopo vanno tutti in giardino a
divertirsi mentre accade qualcosa di
strano
mio dio mio dio delle luci stanno
scoppiando potrebbe essere qualsiasi
cosa ma io faccio che spaventare a morte
senza motivo questo fatto è in realtà
collegato con l'arrivo dei non morti che
finalmente possiamo vedere nella loro
superba bellezza che cazzo di trucco
hanno usato sembra un'enorme big babol
masticato e sputato sulla faccia degli
attori e non venitemi a dire guarda che
un film vecchia perché nello stesso
periodo c'era zombi 2 di lucio fulci che
era affatto 30.000 volte meglio una cara
non deve chiudere gli occhi quando
vedrai piano per stavano sparando dentro
una stanza piena di statue i vasi con
tutto lo schifo di giardino è enorme che
hanno fuori
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma che schifo notare che il nero della
bocca che dovrebbe rappresentare
l'interno in realtà è palesemente una
maschera di gomma
questi zombie fanno proprio paurissima e
tra l'altro solo agili come una carcassa
di ballen arenata sulla spiaggia
dai dai che fra un paio di settimane ci
arrivi da e marche
non lo so se non è un essere umano
non ho più nulla di male è come corrosa
dal tempo
è questa affinchè una reazione spontanea
realistica e come corrosa dal tempo
fantastico o guarda altri gomme da
masticare riempite di fango che poi ok
sono zombie etruschi va bene ma va come
sono vestiti sembrano una mandria di
vecchietti scappati dalla casa di cura e
non scappate
vogliamo solo fare due partite a scala
quaranta è un miracolo di cose l'azione
è perché neanche al professore lo yen è
ospite e poi uno scienziato non dovrebbe
mai mamma ed è mamma questo caso odora
di morte chi chi mai ballerebbe così
[Musica]
fermatevi fermatevi o vi ricordo che
quello che è in mano non è un panino
alla mortadella spara che
no
oh mio dio quanto devi essere imbecille
vuole essere umano riuscirebbe mai a
pulire per marroni sti cosi così lenti
[Musica]
ma torniamo al parco dove l'altra
coppietta non si è accorta di nulla non
è così ti piaccia o altra scena di nudo
e tutte quelle cose che si stavano
dicendo era solo per baciarsi madonna
santa
[Musica]
per l'amor di dio scappate prima che
quello si alza avete tempo di finire di
limonare farvi due spaghetti aglio olio
e peperoncino e scappare camminando dai
nostri evidenti ma davvero
pensavo fosse dei vicini di casa che
avevano finito lo zucchero l'altra
coppia invece ok no questa me la dovete
spiegare la ragazza finisce in una
trappola per orsi
lo so che funziona anche per altri
animali ok ma perché mai è messa lì in
una villa di campagna
dentro al giardino della casa tra
l'altro ma che cazzo succede il tuo film
gli zombie li raggiungono e lui trova un
rastrello enorme infilzava oppure
spaccandolo sulla testa da ben funzione
uguale
[Musica]
non ve lo sprone anche di scrivere ha
palesemente tirato luis messo le mani
sul collo comunque vengono salvati dall
altra coppia a pietrate sulla testa
porca eva st musica sembra che da un
momento all'altro spunti fuori
un'astronave aliena maicon e la madre
rimangono intrappolati in un
seminterrato da uno zombie lucos valgono
di vernice e gli danno fuoco
[Musica]
ok bravissimi ma guardate un attimo
basterebbe spingerlo vie passargli
accanto tranquillamente theo santi
pupazzoni gonfiabili degli stati sono
più favolosi di sti cosi
e siccome anche le auto sono circondate
anno la grandiosa idea di barricarsi in
casa porca [ __ ] ma scappare no ve lo
giuro su dio se calcolassimo la velocità
di camminamento di questi zombie non
raggiungerebbero umane a chi fa un
milione di anni il chilometro orario non
possono semplicemente che ne so andare
via anche camminando piano piano
riuscirebbero a seminarli dentro casa
mandarà una delle cameriere a chiudere
le finestre
no non sto credendo quello che sto
guardando no quello azzurro un cazzo di
ninja
ma come se non fosse abbastanza di
vicolo invece di provare a strappare il
chiodo rimane lì ad urlare comune
rimbambita
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e questo cari amici ascoltatori è stato
etichettato come la più grande stronzata
mai vista da l'uomo viene decapitata
ripeto viene decapitata semplicemente
appoggiando né la falce al collo così
thriller che si taglia con un grissino
mister burford attore porno scopre il
cadavere senza testa e la sua reazione è
impagabile
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e schifosi
maledetti marrani la peste a tutte e due
le nostre famiglie e con discrezione
butta anche il resto del corpo giù è che
amo fare sprecarlo non si butta via
niente
non abbiate paura noi vogliamo solo fare
due tiri a bocce
ora devianti e che partì bene anatomia
umana una tagliola non ti taglia ma ti
procura sono un livido quanti misteri la
scienza la donna dai facili costumi
invece viene presa per i capelli
[Musica]
queste uccisioni in slow motion mi fanno
impazzire
invece di cercare di liberarsi piano
piano vi metterà in cui la mente
trascinata contro un minuscolo coccio di
vetro ma piano e perché sennò sembra
troppo vero non si sa mai
[Musica]
tornando dalla bionda ferita la troviamo
sola è circondata da zombie che tentano
di entrare
[Musica]
il nuovo ti prego aspetta un'altra
mezz'ora per usare quella la bar da
gigante
fortunatamente arrivano tutti gli altri
a salvarla
[Musica]
barca aiuto tra
come fatto essere catturati sempre e
finalmente li uccidono tutti prendiamo
queste porte e le finestre non ne posso
più stammi vicino mamma povero bambino
mio potrai mai perdonarmi di averti
portata in questo posto maledetto si
mamma ti voglio tanto bene vedo tanto
bisogno di sentirti vicino a me di
toccarti da bambino ricordi di tenere
sempre sul tuo seno e a me piaceva tanto
il tuo sito
ecco san severino basta dopo questa ti
saluta avere esce finisci il video ma
finisco cosa mai visto c'è una scena
completamente inutile di accesso tra il
quindicenne e la madre sono mica volani
ma sì ma non sai la cosa peggiore cosa
cosa il bambino è interpretato da un
attore trentenne cosa si chiama peter
burke è affetto da nanismo e per questo
interpreta la parte di un bambino perché
farò una porcata del genere ora capisci
perché devi continuare
va bene a premere che io fortissimo
quindi il bambino trentenne scappa e
scoprì il cadavere della donna uccisa
con i cocci di vetro lei ormai
trasformata lo attacca
poi che chiami gli altri no ma non vedi
che chiaramente vuole un caffè by a
preparar glielo la madre lo va a cercare
mai troppo tardi
[Musica]
fatemi capire bene lei gli strappa un
braccio ma la manica rimane attaccata e
adesso voglio un tutorial i rea come
smembrare in modo facile e pulito dai e
[Musica]
l'espansione ami favorire mentre una si
dispera l'altra sembra una bimba come
una caramella enormi in mano niente
quindi bastava semplicemente scuote di
forte per ucciderli east agenti anche
riusciva a morire contro sti cosi lo
sapevate che in realtà tutti quei morti
viventi facevano parte di un ex squadra
swat
no basta vederli mentre cercano di
sfondare una porta con un ariete come
faccio fatica a credere io che sto
dicendo queste cose figuratevi voi e poi
tutto rallenta come se si entrasse in un
mondo fatto di miele tutto diventa calmo
rallentato quasi fermo e vediamo gli
zombie che con molta calma entrano in
casa salgono le scale camminano nei
corridoi si aggiunge anche il professore
di inizio film che uccide un cameriere
che ovviamente non scappa o i
protagonisti scappano piano piano verso
la chiesa si siedono si riposano porca
eva sto film a ritmo tutto ribaltato
tutto veloce all'inizio è estremamente
falloso
infine per esempio guardate la scena
dove baffo porno va a visitare la chiesa
[Musica]
faccio in tempo a suicidarmi invogliando
dei bicchieri rotti
dopo tre interminabili minuti riesce a
trovare dei frati ma ovviamente sono
anch'essi zombie
ora per farvi rendere conto di quanto
abbia rallentato la trama vediamo
insieme quanto tempo passa da quando si
rende conto che c'è qualcosa che non va
in questi frati a quando scappa stanno
succedendo delle cose molto strane e
avremo bisogno del vostro aiuto
c'è un telefono qui al commento
[Musica]
ok se n'è reso conto non sta scappando
non ancora non ancora facciamone vedere
ancora un paio certo e poi finalmente
riesce ad indietreggiare ma è troppo
tardi
fosse successo nella vita reale sarebbe
andata leggermente in modo diverso
fratelli potete aiutarmi grazie lo
stesso arrivederci gli altri tre
scappano di nuovo e di nuovo si
nascondono perché scappare in una città
grande e troppo mainstream vero essere
una star dei cani modellini ma
ovviamente anche qui è pieno di zombie
solo che questa volta rimangono bloccati
in un angolo
il giornale mike fermati non toccarlo
ecco magari non toccarlo di 30 anni
e quadretti cicinho
[Applauso]
[Musica]
se mi aspettate un secondo vado a
vomitare torno subito le mangia un seno
il figlio di 15 anni interpretato da un
trentenne mangia il seno di sua madre
perché cazzo ma è costretto a guardare
questa bella finisci finisci già 32 voi
non le bastava bene sei contento te l'ho
fatta fare perché tu le hai bisogno ne
avevo bisogno ma tu che cazzo ne sai tu
non ne puoi fare a meno e lo sai bene
lo so che non ne posso fare a me non lo
so adoro scrivere e recitare i miei
video
e allora perché è venuto smettere non ho
voluto smettere ho dovuto smettere
proteiche cazzo vuol dire ogni anno
rinnovarsi trovare battute nuove trovare
fin nuovi che presto cazzo di canale
sono anche finito all'inferno ma
continua a non capire perché non vuoi
continuare perchè ho paura di deludere
qualcuno perché sono un insicuro del
cazzo perché so che non andavo avanti
all'infinito suo canale di youtube
l'idea di loro andranno avanti
all'infinito perché i film finiranno le
battute finiranno e io preferisco
finirlo e prima vanno voglio io
piuttosto che dopo decine di video di
merda sei solo un idiota
vuoi fare altre cose falle ma non
venirmi a dire che mi vuoi fare altre
recensioni perché io non ci credo ma che
ne sai tu ti ho riportato in vita
proprio per questo anche se sono passati
tutti questi anni
tu puoi comunque continuare a fare i
video
e anche volendo è anche volendo
continuare come faccio non mi vedi sono
morto per quello c'è un rimedio
[Musica]